our subject for today
the impotence of omnipotence what did i
say
the impotence of omnipotence
if you guys have i normally don't like
you to have your smartphones on but
you know when we have an opportunity to
bless others go ahead and hit
share and start a watch party and if
you're watching online just share it to
others because you may have friends
online that have not had the privileges
that we have
and so share them but put it on silent
put it off to the side pull out your
bible
dust it off and follow along
with pastor randy skeet i'm so thankful
that we have skeet here today with us
god has sent him here to speak to us
i was able to work as a bible instructor
for a time
in michigan and i lived there in ann
arbor where
pastor randy skeet is living as well
he is a evangelist he's a missionary
he's a preacher
and god has inspired my heart and my
soul
through the words that god has put
through this man
and i've always remembered i remember
watching him online one time and he told
the story
of you know because i don't know if you
guys know but he has
most of the bible memorized if not all
of it but
he was sharing one time how one day he
closed the bible
and i'll never forget that the words
left his mind
so he always will have the bible open
and if you're
following along you will see that it's
as if he's reading right off your page
because the lord is alive and god did
not give him a photographic memory
god just gave him the willpower
to spend time and to take it piece by
piece and we have a new year today you
guys can do the same thing
start this year by putting some of god's
word
in your heart so that you will not sin
against him
may god bless each and every one may god
bless the manservant of the hour today
randy skeet
he will be the next voice you will hear
god bless you
there is nothing save the selfish heart
of man
that lives unto itself no bird that
cleaves the air
no animal that moves upon the ground
but ministers to some other life
there is no leaf of the forest or lowly
blade of grass
but has its ministry every tree
and shrub and leaf pours forth that
element of life
without which neither man nor animal
could live
a man an animal in turn minister to the
life of tree
and shrub unleash the flowers breathe
fragrance and unfold the beauty in
blessing to the world
the sun sheds its light to gladden a
thousand worlds the ocean
itself the source of all our springs and
fountains
receives the streams from every land
but takes to give the mists ascending
from its bosom
fall in showers to water the earth
that it may bring forth and bud
the desire of aegis page 20 paragraph
two
what that paragraph is saying or that
passage
everything created by god
was created to serve something else
only the sinful heart of man
focuses on itself
even in the godhead it is
the other because love is of the center
that's why
god the godhead cannot be one person
love must have someone on which to pour
out
itself and so we thank god for his love
as expressed in the gift of his son we
thank him for you
thank him for your love for his word
that has brought you not only to this
place
but that has brought you online allowing
you to fellowship with us
in this way i welcome those of you
watching who are not
seventh-day adventists wherever you are
thank you very much for your love for
the word of god
and for your affection for us and i ask
the god
of generosity the god of goodness to
bless you
for your participation with us and to
bless you so much
that you will feel that divine urge to
fellowship with us again
if there's anyone listening who has
contracted the coronavirus
i want you to know i am praying for you
and will
be praying for you we serve a god who
says of himself
in exodus 15 26 i am the lord
that healeth thee we serve a god of whom
it is said
in psalm 103 verse 3 who forgiveth all
thine iniquities
who healeth all thy diseases
and of whom the psalmist says in psalm
107 verse 20
he sent his word and healed them
and so i'll be praying for anyone who
may have contracted the coronavirus
that the lord will deliver you and
hopefully by that exercise of divine
mercy
your heart will be touched to be to come
closer to your god
because the bible says we love him
because
he first loved us thank you very much
our subject for today
the impotence of omnipotence what did i
say
the impotence of omnipotence before i
get into that please wherever you are
particularly online preserve an
atmosphere
of reverence as i said last night the
fact that we're worshiping online
does not want wit alter the holiness of
god
god is always holy whether you worship
him
at the backside of a mountain as in the
case of moses
or in the most holy place as in the case
of the high priest or in solomon's
temple
or in this building god's holiness
remains the same
let us preserve reverence wherever we
are
favor number two pray for me while i'm
speaking
all i want you to say is lord put your
words in that man's mouth
this is a very earnest and serious
request
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 says then the
lord put forth his hand
and touch my mouth and the lord said
unto me
behold i have put my words in thy mouth
i want god it's a miraculous thing
the divine god to put his divine word
in my mouth of clay we have this
treasure where
in earthen vessels that the glory may be
of god it has to be god
because clay and dirt cannot do this
and so ask god to give me the words and
the right attitude
and favor number three i want you to
concentrate
and think isaiah 118
come now let us reason together this is
god
inviting us come let's reason
god is reasonable and he's a reasoning
god let's pray
dear god thank you for life
thank you for freedom of worship which
we still enjoy
thank you today god for the technology
that allows us to worship this way
and it allows a preacher to stand in
pennsylvania somewhere
and be watched all over the world dear
god
if we've offended you forgive us father
you love to forgive
that's why calvary exists cleanse me in
a very special way
because it is my heavy heavy duty to
handle spiritual things
tell me what to say tell me when to say
it
tell me how to say it and by the
constant work of your holy spirit their
god
keep my carnal nature under suppression
that your glory alone may be my focus
bless all those listening a very special
blessing on all the
visitors who were not seventh-day
adventists a father an
even more special blessing and all the
little children who may be watching
little boys and little girls touch them
their god because jesus was their age at
some point in his life
now father be merciful to anyone who may
have contracted the coronavirus
in the powerful healing name of jesus
christ
touch them their god and deliver them
and may that expression of mercy draw
them to you
heal any one father listening to me who
may have contracted that virus
rebuke it father and restore them to
health i pray
now i commit this message to your glory
may bless your people
in jesus name amen
let's take a look at jesus christ
let us go to john chapter one we'll read
from verse one
our subject the impotence of
omnipotence john chapter one
reading from verse one john is a very
beautiful book and i
heartily recommend it to you study the
gospel of john it was written
by the man of whom elohite says he most
perfectly of all the disciples developed
the character of christ
so you were listening to the words of a
man who knew christ
intimately by his own choice there is
nothing to prevent you
from being close to jesus make it your
choice john 1
reading from verse 1 i read from the
king james version of the bible
in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god
and the word was god now we're taking a
look at jesus
the same was in the beginning with god
verse 3 all things were made
by him and without him
was not anything made that was made
that's a very powerful statement
all things will accept sin of course
were made by him
if you look at verse one we identified
two personalities
in the beginning was the word and the
word was
with god we have two verse two repeats
that sentiment
the same that's the word was in the
beginning
with god so we have a plurality of
persons
but verse three says all things were
made
by him not them
by him now let me say quickly
this hymn was working for the father
are you with me because christ is the
agent of the father
in creation and in salvation
but it was christ himself who did the
creating
and so the bible says all things were
made
by him now focus on this listen
microscopically
without him was not anything made
that was made nothing can exist
except from sin without christ that
includes the sun
the moon the grass the atmosphere
the fish the birds and humanity
nothing can exist
without the creator you can then
understand why the bible says in acts 17
verse 28
in him we live
and move and have our very being
in christ remove christ and there is no
existence
in him we live and move
and have our being verse 4 in him was
life
and the life was the light of men
verse 14 and the word
became flesh and dwelt among us so we
know the word
is referring to jesus christ in verse 1.
verse 14 clarifies that
beyond any controversy that's why you
study the bible
here a little and there a little line up
online
what's else precept upon precept it is
this
approach adventists use that allows us
to come to such correct conclusions on
our
basic fundamental doctrines now we have
just learned a little about jesus
let's add to that by speaking the words
of someone witnessing about jesus
let's go to hebrews chapter one and
listen to someone
talking about jesus as that person
talks to jesus hebrews chapter 1
let's read from verse 10
well let's read from eight
in hebrews 1 the father is speaking to
the son
follow me closely we are allowed to
eavesdrop by reading the word of god
the father is speaking to the son
verse 8 of hebrews 1 and i ask my father
again to put his words
in my mouth as i speak about his exalted
son
thy throne o god is forever
and ever a scepter of righteousness
is the scepter of thy kingdom now we're
taking a look at jesus our subject is
the impotence of omnipotence
god the father calls jesus
god thy throne or god
god the father declares that jesus has a
throne
which means christ has a kingdom thy
throne or god
is forever and ever a scepter of
righteousness
is the scepter of thy kingdom a scepter
is something the king carries
in africa some leaders carry a fly swap
a tale of an animal
or a stick or a scepter is a visual
symbol
of kingly rule and authority
christ's scepter is righteousness
verse 9 thou hast love righteousness
and hated iniquity therefore god even
thy god
hath anointed me with the oil of
gladness above thy fellows
the father continues to speak listen
closely as he speaks
in verse 10.
referring to jesus christ the son god is
about to say
something about jesus that people
still argue about
god is about to identify jesus christ
as the creator of heaven
and earth and thou lord
in the beginning has laid the
foundations of the earth
and the heavens of the work of thy hands
stop this is god the father
and he's talking to his son and about
his son
and he's talking to us about his son and
god the father says
and thou lord in verse 8 he calls him
god
in verse 10 he calls him lord
and the lord is someone who deserves the
obedience
and the allegiance of subjects many
people want christ as savior
but not as lord he is both as savior
we say deliver me from sin and then let
me lead my life no
jesus says if i am your savior i must
also be
your lord the one who tells you what to
do
and you obey me and so the father
identifies his son
as god he identifies him
as lord thou lord in the beginning
has laid the foundation of the earth and
the heavens
are the works of thy hands so christ is
identified by the father
as the creator they shall perish but
thou remainest
and they all shall wax all as death the
garment
what is god saying his son
is eternal this heaven and this earth
marred by sin will pass away they shall
perish but thou remainest there is a
contrast
between that which is perishable and
that which is eternal
and god the father identifies jesus
christ
as an eternal being verse 12 and they
all shall wax all as if a garment
verse 12 now says and as a vesture shall
thou fall them up
and they shall be changed but thou are
the same
and their years shall not fail
the father is elevating let me
create a word the eternality of god of
jesus christ
he is eternal this is from the lips of
the father
there are some adventists who will tell
you jesus had a beginning
no he didn't then you're contradicting
god
you're contradicting god the father and
his plainly spoken testimony of his son
now
we know from the lips of god that jesus
laid the foundation of the earth let's
go to psalm
90. our subject
the impotence of omnipotence psalm
90 9-0
listen to the psalmist under the
inspiration of the spirit of god
here's what the psalmist writes
god that has been our dwelling place in
all generations
before the mountains are brought forth
or ever thou has formed the earth and
the world
even from everlasting to everlasting
thou art god who formed the mountains
by the lips of god himself in hebrews 1
verse 10
jesus christ and the psalmist is saying
the same thing in the old testament
before the mountains were brought forth
or ever thou has formed the earth and
the world
even from everlasting to everlasting
thou art god
that's the best way a human pen in the
hand of the spirit
can express the eternal nature of the
creator
he doubles up on everlasting
we're taking a look at jesus now
this jesus we've discovered he is god
i didn't say he's the father i said he's
god can you say amen
all right this jesus we discovered he is
eternal
he's everlasting this jesus we
discovered
he is the creator yes at the will of the
father
but it was he who created
having said all of that we go back to
john chapter one
let's go back to john 1 1 1 1 john 1
verse 14 i should say
john chapter 1 verse 14 our subject the
impotence of omnipotence
before we read that verse let me pray
again father in heaven
continue to restrain my cardinal nature
restrain me completely
let me simply be a loudspeaker in your
hands in jesus name i pray
amen john 1 14 listen carefully
keep in mind as you read 14 that we read
in verse 3
all things were made by him and without
him was not anything made that was made
keep that in mind as you listen to verse
and the word was made what flesh
and dwelt among us
and we beheld his glory the glory as of
the only begotten of the father
full of grace and truth this
eternal being this
god as witness by the father this
lord as witness by the father this
creator as witness by the father came
in our human condition
in first timothy chapter 3 verse 16
and without controversy great is the
mystery of godliness
god was manifest in the flesh
god is a mystery was
manifest in the flesh isaiah 9 6 calls
him
the mighty god the everlasting father
not that jesus is the father the
everlasting father may be translated
the father of eternity eternity flows
from jesus
he came to this earth in this
flesh now
while he was on the earth let's see how
powerful he was
let us go to mark chapter 4 we'll read
from verse 37
our subject the impotence of omnipotence
mark chapter 4 reading from verse
i read from the king james version i
don't recall if i told you that
the bible says and there arose a great
storm of wind
and the waves beat into the ship so that
it was now full
and he was in the hindu part of the ship
asleep
on a pillow and they wake him and say
unto him
master carest thou not that we perish
now
and he arose and rebuke the wind
and set into the sea peace be still
and the wind ceased and there was a
great calm
and he said unto them why are you so
fearful
how is it that you have no faith
there were traveling with the one who
said let there be light
they were traveling with the one who
said let the earth bring forth grass
they were fearful verse 41 of mark 4
and they feared exceedingly and said one
to another
what manner of man is this
finish the first that even the wind and
the sea
obey him this is the same god of
psalm 90 verses 1 and 2 from everlasting
to everlasting thou about god
now he is cumbered with humanity but
he's still
god and the wind recognizes him
don't ask me how the wind recognizes god
i have no clue and i need no clue i
accept thus saith the lord
don't ask me how the ravens understood
when god commanded them to feed elijah
and they had to know who elijah was
where he was what time to bring the food
and what food to bring
the bible says god can command the
clouds to not
release the rain isaiah 5 or 6
how that happens i don't know
but i do know that when christ rebuked
the wind
it ceased when christ rebuked the sea
there was a great calm
this is god in human form
and he still has power
now let's go to john 11.
john 11 our subject the impotence of
omnipotence
john 11 verse 43 christ is at the tomb
of lazarus
the bible says john 11 43 and when he
thus had spoken he cried with a loud
voice
lazarus come forth and he that was dead
came forth bound hand and foot with the
grave claws
jesus the one who said let there be
light is the one who said
lazarus come forth this is power
his words brought life from death
by the way it is he of whom the bible
says
for the lord himself shall descend from
heaven with a shout
with the voice of the archangel and with
the trump of god
and the dead in christ shall rise first
when christ
raised lazarus he stood outside the
grave he did not go in
when he comes the second time and raises
all the righteous dead he stands even
farther away he will be somewhere in the
atmosphere and then we will rise to meet
him
but his voice covers any distance
this is omnipotence having
reviewed a part of the resume of jesus
let's go now and be politely shocked
let's go to matthew 13.
our subject the impotence of omnipotence
let's look at the impotence
if that's a proper word to apply to the
creator but i think you understand
or you will in a minute matthew 13
we will read the last verse of that
chapter
do you have it matthew 13 the last verse
of that chapter
the bible says and he did not many
mighty works there because of their
unbelief
now who was this that could not do
anything spectacular
in other words who was this who seemed
to demonstrate some
weakness some impotence some inability
to do something
amazing is the one who said let there be
light
but the bible says he did not many
mighty works there
and the explanation is given because
of the unbelief but mark is a little
more
harsh or bold or blunt let's go to mark
he is recalling or recounting the very
same incident here is how he expresses
it
mark 6 reading verse 5 and verse 6.
mark 6 5 and 6 our subject the impotence
of omnipotence you have mark chapter 6
reading verse 5
and he could he could there do no mighty
work
save that he laid his hand upon a few
sick folk and healed them
verse 6 says and he
marveled at their unbelief
and he could there do no he couldn't do
it
who is this that couldn't do it the
creator
the impotence not that christ is
impotent
you get my point but he was on you see
god
does not reward unbelief
it is an insult to god unbelief is an
insult to god
because unbelief is a refusal to believe
thus saith the lord
let me slow down and say it again i'll
say it differently
the only way to doubt god is to doubt
his word
the only way to believe in god is to
believe
his word
the people in his village where he was
and couldn't do anything spectacular
they did not believe his word
now when you disbelieve the word here is
why it is such
an insult to god
let's go to genesis one we'll read from
verse one our subject
the impotence of omnipotence
genesis one reading from verse one
let me again thank those of you online
for joining us god bless you i really
mean it from my heart
god bless you it shouldn't be too hard
to find genesis 1
chapter 1. reading from verse 1 the
bible says
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters
and god said
when you say something what are you
using
words what is jesus called
john 1 1 in the beginning was the word
what does the bible call him he's the
alpha and the o
mega he's the a and the z
and god said
and god spoke and
god used words
in the book education page 126 paragraph
the servant of the lord writes these
powerful words
the creative energy that called the
worlds into existence
is in the word of god this word imparts
power
it begets life every command is a
promise listen again
the creative energy now only god can
create
human beings can manipulate what god has
created
so we take metals and we take whatever
we manipulate what god has created
no human being can create because
creation means to call into existence
something out of nothing
and so the word of god
he spoke
let there be light he just used words
for every day of creation
the creator use words
when we doubt the word of god
we essentially doubt his ability to
create
we question his status as creator
because the universe came into existence
by the word of god bible commentary
volume 1
page 1081 paragraph 1 god
spoke and his words
created his works in the natural world
nothing was created outside the word of
god
when this word is doubted do you begin
to see the
insult to god
to doubt god's word is to doubt god
himself the very essence of god
and god thinks so highly of his word he
tells us in psalm 138 verse 2
he has magnified his word
above all his name
jesus came to nazareth
they would not believe his word and
because of that
he could not do any mighty work there
matthew said he didn't do it marx is
less than full
and he said he couldn't do it
you and i are gathered for prayer
watch and pray when we pray
we have to pray in what
faith but there is no faith outside of
the word of god
romans 10 17 faith cometh by
hearing come on and hearing by the word
of god
this faith is
leaning your entire weight on the word
of god
faith is taking god at his word
faith is submitting your mind your will
your body your strength your intellect
to the word of god
just before jesus marveled at the
unbelief of those in his hometown
mark 6 6 he had marveled at the belief
of the centurion
are you with me he marveled two things
in the gospels
made christ marvel and i often ask
how do you do something to make the
creator marvel
how here is someone who can say let
there be light
and the light comes let there be a
firmament and it comes how can you do
something to impress god
but the bible says jesus marveled
at the faith of the centurion the bible
says jesus
marveled at the lack of faith
how can you not believe a word that says
let there be light and the light comes
angels come
and the angels came because angels were
also made by the word of god
psalm 148 go there with me reading from
verse one our subject
the impotence of omnipotence psalm 148
reading from verse 1 we read 1 2 and 5.
praise ye the lord praise he the lord
from the heavens praise him in the
heights
praise him all his angels praise him or
his host skepta 5
let them praise the name of the lord for
he commanded
and they were created the
angels were created by the word of god
those
mighty beings they came into existence
out of
absolutely nothing only the word of god
can do that
but where unbelief exists the word of
god
that power is not released it's like
superman in the presence of kryptonite
jesus can't do anything are you
following me he has the power cannot
express it
go to psalm 115 let's read from verse
one our subject
the impotence of omnipotence psalm 115
reading from verse 1 and see how god is
so frequently embarrassed
by our lack of faith psalm 115
reading from verse 1 i'll pray again
father as i proceed through this message
which will not be long continue to pour
your spirit into me not for my sake
father
but for the sake of truth in jesus name
i pray
amen psalm 115 verse 1.
not unto us o lord not unto us but unto
thy name give glory
for thy mercy and for thy truth's sake
now listen carefully
wherefore should the heathen say where
is now their god where is their god
let's modernize that
where is the god of the adventists they
have as much cancer as the rest of the
world
the divorce rate is as high as the rest
of the world their children
are as rebellious as the rest of the
world they are theologically confused as
the rest of the world
they are where is their god
what's the point of this message we call
affectionately
present truth we see no effect in your
life you live as if you have no god and
so the heathens are saying to the
israelites who had disobeyed god
and god could not demonstrate his power
in their lives
where is their god
embarrassment for god but verse 3
but our god is in the heavens
he hath done whatsoever
he have pleased
our unbelief does not weaken god
but it makes god look weak let me say it
again
our unbelief does not weaken god
it makes god look weak
and so our prayers become weak
our worship is weak
because these things are not founded
on faith in the word of god
my brothers and sisters we are in a time
when we must
accept the word of god with a totality
that will approximate recklessness
here's how i usually explain it my
favorite way i hope it is effective
what's the color of this bible you took
too long can you see it
okay it's black now if the bible says
this is white even though you
see black finish my words you must say
white
that's faith in the word of god because
god's word goes absolutely contrary to
the standards of the world
god's word says the seventh day is the
sabbath overwhelmingly the world says no
sunday and so you see sunday
but you have to say saturday
the other examples i can give but i
don't want to cause embarrassment
we're fast approaching a point in this
world where people don't see the point
of marriage
for the sake of having children
a pastor was preaching in the church
once and he said children are for
marriage which is what the bible teaches
a member went to him and asked him to
apologize
apologize for truth but when
something becomes widespread
and persistent it begins to look
normal are you listening to me
it begins to look normal
that's why god told the israelites hear
o israel
the lord our god is one lord deuteronomy
6 from 49
and thou shalt love the lord thy god
with all thy heart
with all thy soul and with all thy might
these words which i command thee shall
be in thine heart and thou shalt teach
them diligently unto thy children
and shall speak of them when thou say
this in night house when the walk is by
the way
when the lie is down when the rise is up
make it
normal by constant
constant constant repetition so that
your children everywhere they turn
they see this and then this becomes
their lives
it is a divine form of brainwashing with
your permission you see
everywhere they turn before they go to
bed
as soon as they arise outside of the
house
in the house that's how the devil
functions
we have to trust the word of god
the bible says bring you all the tithe
into the storehouse
that there may be meat in my house and
prove me now here with saved a lot of
hosts
if i will not open you the windows of
heaven
and pour you out a blessing that there
shall not be room enough to receive it
that word is as certain and as reliable
as let there be light and there was
light
that word is as certain as that the
earth bring forth grass
and the grass came because it proceeds
from the mouth of the same person you
return my tithe i will bless you
beyond your expectation
jesus said in response to the devil
man shall not live by bread alone finish
the verse for me
but by every word
that proceedeth out of the mouth of god
and by the way
what jesus meant was but by by every
commandment
he was referring to the ten commandments
when he said that
maybe if i have time this afternoon i
will show you that biblically
he was referring to the ten commandments
because his ancestor one of them solomon
said
keeping god's commandments this is the
whole
duty of man
question for you don't answer me
is god impotent in your life
because of unbelief
can it be said of you and your
relationship with god
he could do no mighty miracle in her
life
because of unbelief then you look across
the pew
and you see how god is blessing some
other person and you're jealous
and envious and resentful not realizing
that person has
put faith in the word of god
and you haven't god
always honors faith
the bible says without faith come on
finish it
it is impossible
and the only way to have faith is in
god's word
which means you and i must make the word
of god
our lifestyle this morning
i was telling sister angela i'll tell
her now
i spoke at seven o'clock this morning
for church in england
i thought it was supposed to be five
they were five hours ahead of us
and i miscalculated and i thought i had
to speak
at five this afternoon because they met
at 12 noon but they're ahead of us
and i had to speak i had to jump out of
the bed and the lord woke me up
and i thanked him and i made a special
financial offering to him for just
waking me up on time
to rush down and speak to god's people
in england because i had confused the
time
what am i saying
this morning
noon night this
trusting the word of god living by the
word of god
praying through the word of god
when jehoshaphat i'm closing prayed
because he was under threat from three
armies second chronicles chapter 20.
if you read his prayer from verse 6 to
12 he keeps calling on god he says
art now art not thou god in heaven and
the bible says he is
and rule is not thou over all the
nations of the earth the bible says yes
and is it not power in thy hand the
bible says yes
so uh jehoshaphat was praying
biblically and when you present god with
his word
god will not avoid it or ignore it
let me place this on your mind your
heart before i close
preachers say i'm closing five or six
times
but i am closing god
is not obligated to you
or me he is obligated
to his word now if the word is in you
when god fulfills that obligation where
is it fulfilled
in you ah you missed it
it's my fault let me try again
if you pull the pin from a hand grenade
and you throw it
it'll explode somewhere away from you
are you following me
if you pull the pin and hug it to your
bosom it explodes in you now
god's word is a hand grenade full of
power that saves not blows you up it
puts you together
you pull that pin of faith in your heart
when it explodes
it releases saving power it releases
transforming power
it heals diseases it brings back the
wandering family member back to the
truth
it clarifies your thinking when the word
of god
is fulfilled in you let me repeat with
respect
god owes you mean nothing you cannot
place
god under obligation to creation god is
obligated
to his word
and he'll always always fulfill his word
because the word of god cannot be broken
i call upon you in the presence of this
holy god
re-evaluate your attitude towards thus
saith the lord
take it as it reads
believe it we charge god with being
unfair
and unfeeling and unkind because we do
not approach him in faith we do not take
him at his word
and consequently god cannot do what he
desires to do for us i told you earlier
god does not bless unbelief
jesus lived by faith in the word of god
in john chapter 8 verse 29 jesus
testifies this way
and he that have sent me is with me
the father hath not left me alone for i
do always those things that please him
focus on that statement i do always
those things
that please him jesus said my object was
always to please the father
hebrews 11 6 says without faith it is
impossible to please god
so if jesus pleased god what kind of
life did jesus live
a life of faith the only way to live a
life of faith
is to live a life by the word of god and
jesus christ himself said
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word
and when jesus said man he included
himself the impotence
of omnipotence in the absence of faith
we tend to see god as omnipotent he's
doing nothing
god will never reward doubt
your faith does not have to be
mountainous like mount rushmore
but you must exercise all that you have
like the father in mark 10 who brought
his epileptic boy to be healed the
disciples can heal him
and he said if thou can't do anything
have mercy upon us and help us
and jesus says if thou canst believe all
things are possible the man said lord i
believe and he cried
help thou my unbelief elohim i said when
you say that prayer you cannot be lost
help my unbelief this is all the faith i
have jesus says that's all the faith i
need from you i just need what you have
god does not require elijah's faith from
you he requires
your faith from you and this is all you
have
exercise it
when you exercise this god responds with
that
ah you missed it again when you exercise
this amount of faith god responds with
that
we see that in how god rewards people
none of us has lived forever even if we
we live
righteous lies we have not lived forever
yet
god rewards us with life forever
those of us who live sinful lives he
rewards us with
this amount of punishment is brief and
he blots you out he does not let you
suffer forever
so when god rewards he rewards
when he punishes he punishes only so
much
if you love god say amen i love god
and i like god he is a nice
person believe his word
obey it i know we hate the word obey
it causes us to a gag the carnal nature
gags on the word obey
but it is life to the believer obey god
do what god tells you
god will bless your life let's bow our
heads and pray father in heaven
we thank you for the power of our savior
we thank you for your power
we thank you for the power of the holy
spirit we thank you for the angels that
excel in strength
lord all the power of heaven
is available for the weakest sinner who
needs it
help us to believe that their god all
the power of heaven is available
to the weakest sinner who exercises
whatever little faith he or she has
dear god forgive us for lack of
faith you're not angry with us because
our faith is little
you're concerned because we do not
express that little faith
if we have faith as a mustard seed says
jesus
we shall say to this mountain be removed
and be cast into the sea
and it will move please
god give us a dose of divine common
sense
to make the connection between faith
and the exercise of your power let us
stop
making you look weak and impotent
because you are
omnipotent bless everyone who heard the
message they
got if i said something i should not
have said forgive me father
i mean the words that your people heard
long remain in their hearts
and let that living word that made
heaven and earth transform their lives
help us to live by faith that grows
every day
i pray from my heart in jesus name amen
[Music]
you